Looking back at our code, here is how we would expect that to play out.
We might build amy and ben such that they delegated to Car.methods rather than
copying all of the Car.methods properties onto amy and
ben here when they're stored in the obj variable.
That way when we go looking for
amy.move, even though the amy object doesn't have its own .move property, we'll
delegate that lookup to the Car.methods object which does have a move property.
Let's see how that looks in practice.
The problem here is we're using an object literal, these two curly braces, in
order to build the brand new object, that's going to be an instance of car and
whatever you use in object literal to create an object,
you don't get to define what the prototype of that new object is going to be.
So we're going to have to switch it up and use our other technique for
creating objects, which is object.create that technique does allow us to
set the prototype of the new object.
Now whatever we put in here, in between these parenthesis,
is going to be the thing that our new object delegates to.
So what object do you expect we're going to need to pass to object.create in
order to set up the right delegation relationship for every new instance of car.
Note we aren't done refactoring the rest of the code yet, but
before I move on I do want to get this line right.